all right original grain you know it or
you live under a rock yep honestly this
is my favorite one
i like the way it looks because it's got
some bulb to it look at that that one's
[ __ ] sick but also i look like nice
and like when i hold the microphone like
this everyone can tell i'm sexy
it's the last chance here go to
originalgrain.com
lifeline for 30 off it's the last chance
here to get stuff for father's day we
have the perfect gift for every dad okay
and i know i'm a dad and i'm wearing it
and also check out these sunglasses that
they have
uh [ __ ] sick ring i love rings yep
it's a sick ring so look uh
originalgrain.com lifeline for 30 off uh
and do it before father's day uh we've
been making watches from unique
materials for almost a decade and i say
we even though i'm not part of original
grain when i wear the watch i feel like
we're all doing something that's better
for this world because i'll tell you
what they also every time you make a
purchase they plant a tree
so it's good for the environment and
it's a veteran and family-owned company
started by two brothers
right not us but like us in the pacific
northwest uh over twenty thousand five
star reviews
and uh all you gotta do is use code
lifeline at
originalgrain.com lifeline to get 30 off
site-wide so go and check it out and get
some father's day and just at least
peruse right uh they make uh watches
from other sustainable materials like
100 recycled ocean plastic reclaim
military ammo wood crates anyway you're
a good person if you make a purchase
from here they're good people for having
this company like this
so check it out that's code lifeline at
originalgrain.com
lifeline to get 30 off site wide get
your father's day gift taken care of
today
lifeline is an advice show for
entertainment purposes only if you need
real help or advice please seek a
therapist or a licensed professional
[Music]
hit the clock
all right here we go ready you know
uh ready yeah dude okay
um
all you got to do is hit it though i
know but there you go
you did it
now how come you know
okay how come every time you sing a song
you make it sound like it's a [ __ ]
opera song with the vibrato
yeah man
now you know how i said i didn't like
how you wore sunglasses sometimes now
you're weird so i'm wearing sunglasses
and do you know why i'm wearing
sunglasses because i found them for this
well these that's why i'm wearing these
sunglasses but the reason i'm wearing
sunglasses at all is because i also feel
[ __ ] ugly as [ __ ] today
so i can
relate check this out check this out you
see this yeah it's like it's my elbow
doesn't move that much but my [ __ ]
nose your elbow is moving so
but mainly it's my arm no it's not your
elbows
wow look how [ __ ] good that looks
dude it doesn't look good so now my
elbow hurts is the other yeah yeah but
you yeah
the [ __ ] last cowboy i'm keeping it
live dude um anyway dude let's just you
know bring it down a little bit you know
what i'm saying and a matter of fact if
you're gonna wear sunglasses i'm just
gonna keep it cool and real personal
okay because i'm personal because you
don't look ugly today i don't i actually
don't feel like i look ugly today but
i'll tell you where right now what's
[ __ ] going crazy or my allergies dude
i woke up yesterday i was so i went in
the pool two days ago
and i took calvin in because he kept
saying you want to go in the pool i did
it and i go like hey what the [ __ ] i get
in there and it's it pulls murky but
what do you mean murky like it's like
you know how you can usually see all the
way to the bottom yeah you can still see
the bottom but it's a little bit
cloudier
so why'd you make that because that's
what murky is okay so you ask me so just
say it's a little cloudier though why
did you bring up the bottom one you can
see the bottom anyway because murky it's
murkier than normal and when you talk
about something being opaque or not then
it's
water it's murky opaque you would say
it's murky you would say that air's
murky okay
so anyway dude i go in the i'm like all
right well he wants to go in and i go in
and then my [ __ ] and then my
assistant comes out and she says you
know what
you can't you the pool guy didn't come
last week and he didn't come today
either and i was like he was supposed to
come today so what the [ __ ] so i fire
off some emails and then after i got to
the pool i i figure the pool guy comes
and it's not even i fire off some emails
and i didn't mean to i'm like where's
the pool guy is everything going okay
and then he showed up so now i got that
email out there and everyone's gonna
[ __ ] think i'm a dick because i
didn't wait in there but also he didn't
come last week so that's why it's murky
so what why my question is why does your
pool guy need to come every week why did
your pool get so [ __ ] murky dude i
didn't know that either but if you if
you don't have your pool up kept you're
supposed to it says three to six days
you're supposed to have the pool guy
come every three to six days i know
that's that's no you know who made that
rule that's crazy i know [ __ ] pool
guys it's crazy but it but after two
weeks or whatever two and a half weeks
it was like it honestly looked a little
bit murky
and and so i i went in anyway and my
assistant like is fine don't worry about
it trust me it's fine and then i woke up
the next day
and i felt all [ __ ] clogged up and i
was like it's because of the algae you
know guys die like this if someone had
like a little piece of diarrhea on their
anus and went in the pool
everyone dies did you know that if you
have a little bowel if you have a little
piece of diarrhea if you do diarrhea i
have a question who has a little piece
of diarrhea people who do diarrhea i
mean i've done diarrhea yeah do you
think you'd get rid of all of the
diarrhea i don't [ __ ] damn well dude
no you need to take a shower after your
diarrhea
so anyway
i i went i i i don't have diarrhea but
i'm like i don't know if anyone in my
house has diarrhea i have a son right he
could i mean you actually you probably
know if he has diarrhea yeah i know but
also he could like i don't even know
what it looks like if he like sometimes
kids have diarrhea like a little bit you
know like kids are always like some kind
of sick right so i'm like i don't know
so i'm like
so i'm like are you sure it's okay and
she's like yeah trust me it's fine and i
went in the pool and then the next day i
woke up
you know now i realize it's allergies
but it was [ __ ] crazy and i was like
the algae in the pool gave me [ __ ]
i'm gonna die and she was like you're
not and then kristen and her were
laughing at me but dude whatever man why
can we get back to why a little bit of
diarrhea kills a bunch of people because
if you have a little bit of diarrhea in
water and then it [ __ ] and then you
leave and then in a week i mean that
bacteria goes nuts man it's like ibiza
for
for algae but don't you have
a [ __ ] cleaner in the pool
like a thing yeah but you needed to be
the ph balance and also the chlorine you
don't have a [ __ ] pool this sounds
too dangerous and there's a chlorine
yeah if you have diarrhea you just don't
go in the pool
but no one knows that rule yeah yeah you
they do dude have you ever seen
apartment complexes when they're like
don't come in there was a diarrhea
catastrophe or whatever the [ __ ] the
[ __ ] yeah for real in apartment they're
like please do not come in the pool we
have to really figure this out because
diarrhea has been in here that's what
public pools dude yeah man they people
die off that [ __ ] you go take one you
think you're gonna have a nice summer
day and you walk out with a little
diarrhea in your ear you're dead because
diarrhea doesn't just go in your mouth
it goes in your ear it's in your brain
it's all [ __ ] up man the bacteria goes
nuts it's ibiza in there forever what
killed you murky obesity what killed
your friend uh diarrhea that wasn't my
friend i just read it i know i'm doing
it like
like it happened in the world in the
wild
what killed your friend diarrhea yeah
that's the saddest way to die on pools
it'll say it says persons having
currently active diarrhea or who have
had active diarrhea within the previous
14 days do not enter the pool 14 days
yep
14 14 days yeah 14 days dude that's two
weeks they should just say two weeks
honestly yeah
it sounds so much worse 14 days
for a few weeks say a few if you have a
diary so you mean to tell me
if someone had diarrhea 13 days ago
everyone's dead it could still be on
their [ __ ] ass it's the amoebas and
[ __ ] you know how small they are you
don't know anything when someone says
i'm the one who's [ __ ] educating you
about diarrhea's impossible when someone
says it's the amoebas and [ __ ]
rest assured they don't know what the
[ __ ] they're talking about i do it for
the layman's dude like there's a lot of
scientists that watch our show obviously
but a lot of more way more laymen so i'm
like [ __ ] telling people
yes about the amoeba and shits so the
laymans go like this oh okay the
layman's yeah
okay
so anyway yeah
if you have diarrhea
13 days ago and you take a dip and
there's no cleaner in the pool everyone
dies yes so it's hiroshima and word to
the wise don't
diarrhea and swim anytime soon how much
would it suck if you were working out
for that summer body getting a nice tan
summer was coming it's the first hot day
you know and you're just like oh can't
wait to go to my pool and then you
realize [ __ ] man 12 days ago i had
diarrhea i don't think that if you're
sanitary you need to worry about that
who who diarrheas and doesn't shower for
13 [ __ ] days who's doing that you're
not it's not not showering i'm just
saying there could be a little piece
diary is really small dude diarrhea
amoebas are really small
diarrhea in the murky water
yeah man pick up the movie on the air
out where the rub still leave it like
that
i heard your voice so bad
i know the little amoebas in in [ __ ]
murky ibiza i know what bo don't know
and then another diarrhea comes touch
them up and go and then it gets in your
ear and you go uh oh why do you die
dude that's what happens
start lower because it's right
no no no no no no no no no no no
i guess so and then [ __ ] uh
touch them up and go
in the ear
and then you go uh oh
and then you run to the bottom
and then you're [ __ ] with your legs
up big all day we'll be on the area
[Laughter]
wait wait wait wait i have another
question do you get diarrhea from other
people with diarrhea or you just die oh
i don't know actually that's a good
question or you just have a bad stuff
pickled movie on the air yeah yeah
that's right yeah still living still
well not live it anymore
yeah yeah yeah anyway dude i guess we're
going to stop singing though because
it's hurting i mean a lot of people
would really like that especially the
scientists that watch this they'd be
like oh i see it's like a musical
[ __ ] educational music
so what we're going to do is we're going
to stop singing that's fine i'm out of
breath anyway okay cool but how about um
so anyway it's not the
i don't have al it's my
it's definitely um what do you call it
uh diarrhea allergies
oh i see yeah and i was trying to do the
thing where i where i was sleeping
this morning and moving the
[ __ ] down and then i would sleep it and
i'm moving the [ __ ] you know how it
changed the
snot in your nose will change and should
you go to one oh yeah then i move over
to the other side so i can breathe out
of the other should we talk about the
thing that you and i both have and we
both just realized we both have it and
no one else in the [ __ ] world has it
the thing with our nostril this thing
yeah dude i think you know who else has
it theo vaughn he does yeah he dude
he'll be doing the podcast and he's like
he's doing this dude what is this it's
an epidemic i'm like what are you doing
dude are you doing this he's like man i
can't really breathe out i'm like dude
me and my brother but i'll tell you what
well didn't you have the sinus surgery i
did i'm gonna have that did you know
that no no but i dude i i only had it
after the sinus surgery so i don't know
wow
well i'm gonna have uh the sign of
surgery because my [ __ ] is really curvy
dude when i went into the [ __ ] doctor
before i had my sinus surgery my doctor
said was like he sat down
he got a couple brochures he went out of
the room came back in with the brochures
got all solomon [ __ ] and asked me about
my cocaine problem seriously and i was
like i
i i know you think i'm gonna be lying
when i say this but that's the one drug
i've just never done oh my god yeah and
he was like i don't know like he didn't
oh really
i mean like
he was like [ __ ] shore he got brochures
before he even [ __ ] asked me
what was a brochure like it was like how
to stop using cocaine wow dude yeah i
was like i i my nose is busted i guess
but i've never done cocaine i swear he
was like real
sure dude is that because of the time
where you ran around the corner and
bumped your nose into the [ __ ] kid's
head probably i mean i don't know
because i had the surgery after that
because my nose
was like this that's what mine was like
no but oh you had this right after that
right i ran into the girl's forehead
right wow and my nose was like this
i was such a [ __ ] heart ass at the
time though i didn't even say [ __ ] i
know i came home and mom was like what
happened your [ __ ] face yeah i was
like what i looked in the mirror my nose
is like this
wow look all crooked like this
and you have surgery then yeah because
it was like if i kept growing my nose
would have been like this by the time i
loved it dude got it i definitely would
have been the hot brother i would have
been the owen wilson brother yeah right
um
strangely he's kind of the hot brother
out of the tool is he though i think so
i think girls think he's sexy sexier
than luke luke's kind of just kind of
normal and he's kind of just got that
[ __ ] but normal is better than
[ __ ] yeah when it comes to like
people
no one likes blonde guys no no i know
that blonde guys are [ __ ] all
extremely ugly but no one's ever liked a
blonde guy no i know i've never seen a
blonde guy that's good-looking no one in
history
a no gay man or heterosexual woman has
ever been attracted to a blonde not over
a brunette dude no no way no [ __ ] way
dude but also just
never no i know never okay never and
also if it's up to liking a blonde dude
or a brunette dude a girl would
literally [ __ ] shoot the blonde dude
in the head with an arrow oh just just
to breathe in the same room yes as a guy
who has darker hair even though even if
he's [ __ ] three foot six because
blondes are [ __ ]
so ugly yeah and they're all ugly and um
and uh not blind women there's just no
blondes men no [ __ ] and if you're a
blonde man and you wear a [ __ ]
leather jacket like you're hiding your
ugliness and all of a sudden you're cool
lop your head off so
so [ __ ] lop your head off like this
shing and then have it just go
you don't control what sorry you do with
your head after you cut it off
no i know what i'm saying you you lop it
off like this and then you wait and then
it just kind of teases you oh you wait
all right after you lop your [ __ ]
head off yeah you wait forever but what
i'm saying is you know the [ __ ] you
know the movies when a [ __ ] samurai
guy goes
and you're like ooh did he get him did
he get him and the guy
yeah and his [ __ ] face i do know and
you're like oh he got him i do know that
movies are dumb dude movies are dumb
people think [ __ ] just because it
happens in movies yeah it's true it's
really really stupid top gun we got a
[ __ ] we got to see top gun dude
everyone's saying how good it is i know
it all guess what it's not i know all it
is is a bunch of guys smirking i didn't
see it but guess what it's not how many
times in topcon do they go like this
[Music]
probably everybody
300 more than 300 in the class in the
class where they're [ __ ] like yeah
guy with the toothpick dude you guys got
a [ __ ] toothpick did you know that's
so dumb that guy's like
you're just smirking and the guy's
flying just just smirking it you can't
see the [ __ ] you're flying yeah
that's true but did you know you have
you seen the first top gun the parts
parts it's that's a movie that don't
make don't remake a movie [ __ ] 30
years later not remake but couldn't
agree more yeah it's like but that
wasn't you remember how that wasn't my
question what's the question have you
ever seen them not all the way through i
answered that okay
okay okay okay but the point is you know
how anthony you'll get some questions
anthony edwards is in the first one and
he dies and he's goose ruined it but yes
he
miles teller plays his son in this one
that's not good dude but also that's not
good for anybody but also
wouldn't he be older miles tell her
son would be like 50 no
no i mean how long ago he was on 40 when
he was in top gun wasn't he but he was
probably like an infant and then so no i
mean it makes sense there's some
timeline issues here they're not going
for [ __ ] reality
maverick patrick stewart should be
should play
oh yes up in the air like this yeah
smirking oh clouds yes
um
so anyway dude top gun's probably bad
stop saying it's good stop saying it's
good stop don't don't remake a movie
don't sorry i see keep saying remake but
the truth it's like the matrix dude
don't make the trilogy come 30 years
later make
new [ __ ] no but they won't do that but
do it
i i guess man i don't know i mean all
people do is recycle [ __ ] that happened
before the year 2000
that's all that ever happens because
they didn't think that's gonna what's
gonna start really making movies that
weren't even hit so i can't wait for
that the absolute [ __ ] lulu they are
yeah nothing new will ex will be made in
12 years from now
okay you said you heard it here yeah you
heard it here first all right well let's
get to some questions how this is
lifeline it's in a vice show right it is
and we've just kind of been [ __ ] i
know you guys like it sometimes when we
[ __ ] so we [ __ ] a little bit
also remember we had that debacle when
[ __ ] chris our producer didn't have
enough videos oh yeah yeah that was
horrible so um anyway we're good now
dude and maybe we have some videos maybe
we have enough maybe we don't but here
we go baby
hi chris and matt my name's hannah
i need advice about a co-worker
relationship
my work with this woman
monday to friday nine hours a day and
she tells horrible stories there's no
point to them
no arc there's no beginning middle or
end she just
starts off on a story that has no point
and i don't even know what part i'm
supposed to be reacting to wow because
nothing happens in them so i just do a
lot of
wow that's crazy and uh you know like
fake laughing
and it's getting really exhausting and i
don't know maybe i should spin move out
of this one
probably not gonna work so any advice
you can give me would be great i don't
know if i should say hey these stories
suck i don't know what you want from me
or if i just keep fake laughing
let me know i love you guys so much
you have no idea oh thanks i love you
too it is
a predicament i i i here's what i would
do okay at this
i don't know if i would advise this but
this is what i would do i would start
and then
increasingly do this i would start to do
this and then increasingly do it louder
and louder until she inquired about what
the [ __ ] i was doing right i would just
start saying
oh
all right and then longer and longer oh
and like over her story so she knows you
yeah she knows you're not even hearing
her anymore you know and then she would
be like what are you doing
what are you doing right exactly and
then you just be like
that's all i it's all i don't know yeah
what are you doing yeah yeah
yeah um and then take it from there but
take it from that type of conversation
about it i think um well first of all
part of me wants to be like this is part
of your job like whatever job you have
that's the part of it for also you have
too many drinks out here right i'm ready
dude we have too many drinks i'm always
thirsty at the end so i came [ __ ]
ready okay
you hate [ __ ] like this right yeah dude
why
like dude no
first of all there's two you have two of
these you should only have one of them
look at what i do i keep my [ __ ] clear
because i want people to be seeing
[ __ ] who cares shut the [ __ ] up the
shot's all boring why don't you like
this
the shot's dirty you're not in a [ __ ]
you know what i mean
a [ __ ] what's his name movie
what movie the [ __ ] guy who did the
uh look though my coffee's traffic who
did traffic steven soderbergh my
coffee's hot my coffee's hot
it's an awfully hot coffee
drinking like a dildo
all right
yeah my [ __ ] coffee's eye dude dude
what the [ __ ] dude
um
i should do cat drink my coffee man
okay um
so anyway
advisor okay so um [ __ ] now i'm hot and
[ __ ] oh good dude um i could not be man
you're sucking it in a dildo you know
um [ __ ] so
i think that it's part of your job you
don't know what your job is but that
sucks but also just be like um
i mean i don't know i i what i would do
is i would say like i mean i do it to my
i have a friend that he's kind of guilty
of this he'll
he'll be like did i tell you about this
chick
and i'll be like no and he'll be like
about the chick that i met
the at the thing and i'm like no
and and then he'll be like okay so
and then it take he'll like do this
preamble of like you didn't even start
the goddamn nobody nobody needs a
preamble you didn't even you didn't even
like and i and i you didn't even like
say you didn't even say anything yet you
know it's like it's like
so
so there's multiple ways of telling bad
stories it sounds like she's just wants
to talk to hear herself talk it sounds
like she's actually impressively bad at
it well yeah i do too that's the other
thing too here's what i would advise
advise
her
is
have fun with it dude i would love to
hear a story like that yeah you would
because
it blows my mind that people like i have
friends that do that and kristen will be
like
how do you hang out with that person
yeah you and i say because it's so fun
you have the always had you have always
had the weirdest friends i know dude i
really have now right now you have the
least weird in your i know
i need to get back to weird friends but
i do have some but but i just have fun
with it dude this is a gift she's giving
you a gift this lady is giving you a
gift she's being boring as [ __ ] which
means you are allowed to just take that
brain time off right she's saying what
she's saying think about whatever you
want and have fun with it do the o thing
like that yeah
yeah just i mean
are you worried about hurting her
feelings or what i don't know why you
would be though because
she's clearly oblivious to
a lot if she's telling stories like this
do an intervention with her but at a
certain point just like do whatever the
[ __ ] you want don't fake laugh don't
don't be courteous yeah you don't have
to be rude but just be
weird see what happens like this woman
clearly is something's a little bit
wrong in her head
like who the [ __ ] tells stories like
that that's a very strange thing to do
you don't begin you have no end it's
just like you just are saying words
you know he could do this is a really
great way to have fun with it
she tells her story it's very boring
yeah
keep
keep bringing it up afterwards yeah yeah
like every day multiple times a day yeah
like i can't stop thinking about
actually like that was the way you told
me like it's really crazy you were at
the park right and you saw that guy
doing karate like yeah you know
what do you think he's doing yeah yeah
and just keep bringing it up and having
her be like
having her be the this is great having
her be the one who was like why do you
keep asking about this i was like well
because it was obviously really
important to you yeah and like you know
and then she'll stop telling you stories
for sure
but then even keep bringing it up yeah
never call her late call her one text
her email her on your work god that's
crazy about the karate guy or whatever
the [ __ ] story
you know on your work email keep a
conversation this is great i wish
subject matter
subject remember the karate guy yeah
yeah yeah
karate guy update and then in the body
anything karate guy memorial
um all right cool that's great advice
that was good advice yeah all right cool
next one
what's up chris and matt uh my name is
norma jean i'm from southern oregon it's
my dog um i have some breakup advice
question for you guys i
am
30 and going through my first breakup in
a very long time i spent
most of my 20s single and haven't been
through a breakup in a long time and i
need my community a lot
and i think i'm making the right choice
and man i keep trying to do this video
without crying but pity um
breakups are sad and um
i don't want to wear my friends out with
it but i do need them
and
you know i guess my question is when do
i know that my friends are [ __ ] sick
of it
is there like a timeline like you get 30
days
um
just maybe some general rules about
breakups and how you guys approach them
and how you support friends and breakups
and um
maybe some words uh thanks for the
podcast
and i look forward to hearing from you
guys thanks
that's my favorite person that has
called into the show so far yeah you
like the realness of it yeah um so i
think that they're not your friend if
they get sick of your thing about being
broken up it doesn't there is no [ __ ]
time limit there is no nothing if you're
if your friends are like oh my god she's
going on again about the breakup i i
actually think they're not really that
good yeah yeah yeah i've had friends
that have gone on and on and on about it
for [ __ ] months and months and months
right and i'll tell you this though i
mean this ought to make you feel good
it's just true though i'm not trying to
make you feel good
it always ends up the same way
the person [ __ ] moves on and forgets
and ends up was with someone else
and that is a better relationship that's
happened to every single [ __ ] time
me me or any of my friends who have come
to me about breakup advice yeah or
wanted just to [ __ ] wallow about the
breakup it's always the case
that they end up not only forgetting
about it but in a relationship that they
are better off in so my advice to you is
don't worry about wearing your friends
out
that's it yeah well if this is your time
right yeah exactly like like i guess
that's what i would say like you're this
is what your friends are here for if
you're if you're not building up like
goodwill with your friends and [ __ ]
being friends to them then this is your
time where you get to only worry about
yourself worry about yourself but also
like just worry about yourself take some
[ __ ] me time i hate when people say
that but you know i have a feeling
probably you know
you couldn't get through this video
without crying because of the realness
but also because you i noticed you have
a dream catcher a lot of women who dream
catchers cry more normal than women who
don't have dreams now here's my question
yeah
what
is a dream catcher it's the thing in the
back that was a circle that people hang
on their car if you have some people
have a lot of people have two they'll
have one in their room and then one in
their car and they're on their
windshield those people cry a lot okay
are you talking [ __ ] about her i mean
i'm lightly just having fun okay but
also careful though because if you talk
[ __ ] no i love it
with overalls is
and also she's very she's obviously very
sweet and also crying isn't bad crying
is great no crying's great but like
here's the deal though
where's the cut off and i'm going to
play devil's advocate because i
understand you're like it doesn't matter
how long but where's the cutoff
six months okay a year bro if my buddy
was like man this chick a year and a
half later it sounds like it's recent
okay and i'm on her side and i think
that you should talk about it with your
friends as much as you want and i'm sure
they want to be there for you too
because if they're not going to be there
for the shitty friends right but also
where's the cutoff
well she's not going to be wallowing for
a year look look at her she's [ __ ]
great she's going to have [ __ ] pick
of the litter in no time i know but i'm
just saying
there's got to be some sort of cut off
give yourself a [ __ ] cut off too you
can do that i mean if you're just
talking about wendy's
also just i think broadly the broader
advice here is that
don't
she said a month she was like a month
she said it is a month too long oh no no
for example way longer yeah yeah but my
advice to you is don't worry about when
the end is going to come
because when you're worrying about when
the end is going to come
that's when the end never prolongs the
end you just spoke over me very very
very poignant and that's a lot like john
lennon and john lennon once said stop
bringing up john lennon quotes you don't
even know all right you always do this
he said something about like
you always bring up [ __ ] john lennon you
don't even know what it was dude
something about time i can't [ __ ]
remember oh
okay you don't even remember any more
words than just you know much about john
lennon i'm just saying no [ __ ] somebody
out there said something really [ __ ]
poignant about something that what
you're saying and they said it probably
better than you did no i said it [ __ ]
great yeah and you spoke over it okay
don't worry about when the end is gonna
come when you're worrying about when the
end is gonna come the end never comes
just [ __ ] hang out with your dog hang
out with your friends talk about it as
much as you want think about whatever
the [ __ ] you want to think about but
don't think about when the end's going
to come because that is when the end
will never [ __ ] come get it it
doesn't matt i'm not saying stop
thinking about it you think about what
you think about but don't try to hurry
it the [ __ ] up it's going to come when
it's going to come but it's never going
to come when you're worrying about when
it's going to come all right so but then
you're saying think about you're going
to think about what we're going to think
about it's okay for her to think about
what she's thinking about right but it's
not okay for me to be thinking about
when i'm talking about john lennon
and that's shitty right why are you
making it about you i'm not i'm saying
it's okay to think about what you're
going to think about as a person but
also when i mentioned the john lennon
thing you're like don't mention john
lemon but that's what i'm thinking i
only say that about john lennon because
you don't know what the thing john
lennon said is and you say that's like a
thing john lennon said and then you
don't even know what it was you're gonna
be fine bottom line is you you can tell
you're a very sweet woman and you're a
ve you got that dog that's very sweet
and you obviously care and you have some
sort of like um
quality about you that's very like um
[Music]
i mean that dream catcher like it's very
nice to be like believing in things and
like
hoping for the best like it's a very
spiritual kind of a i think you're going
to be well you are going to be fine yeah
she's the best she's the best person
that um okay ask for our advice all
right well she's the very very best okay
sorry to everyone else she's the very
number one best i mean we don't know but
yeah she knows she was definitely good
yeah i know she was a lot better than
the [ __ ] guy with the towel on his
head i'll tell you that much no remember
the [ __ ] guy um
no a lot better than the guy who had the
[ __ ] towel on his head or the guy who
had the big eyes and the big mouth
yeah we've had some bad um but she's
great
and and we and it's great yeah and now i
gotta do dates because i forgot to do it
oh i know atlanta washington dc stockton
oakland peoria illinois i'm coming
chrisleya.com raleigh north carolina
savannah georgia chrislea.com denver
colorado boston massachusetts
jacksonville florida and this week i'm
going on sale with lakeland and also
dallas which is grand prairie the grand
prairie area and then also another one i
think kansas so go to chrisley.com and
get your tickets but that was great man
things are going to work out for you
so rude go ahead what's the next one
hey chris hey man jason love the show
love you guys you already
know all right
taking breaks on social media so i know
it's absolutely necessary everyone
should take breaks when they need to
uh i would just like to know maybe your
perspective on how you navigate
breaks from social media
especially if there's an influence of
income from your social media presence
so with that is there such thing as too
long of a break or should you just not
even care and always
take as much of a break as you need no
matter what income is influenced uh good
or bad so would love to know your guys's
thoughts on that i'm kind of going
through that dilemma myself and you know
just hearing your guys personal
experience i think will will help a lot
in that uh in that situation so
appreciate you guys bye-bye
he's [ __ ] hilarious i know he's so
hilarious on tick-tock or instagram or
whatever it is yeah every time he
comments on my thing his name is like
jason rodello or something and every
time he comments on my thing i'm like oh
[ __ ] jason derulo commented on my [ __ ]
no but and then better than him
dance is better than jason way better
that's [ __ ] hilarious way better he
reminds me of uh first time i saw him i
was like that's like alpha molina and
boogie yeah yeah yeah yeah 100 he's like
out for molina when he was a kid so um
well anyway
he
he is very funny uh yeah okay i have a
[ __ ] thing about this actually um
you got to make those racks right if
that's how you're making racks and
that's how you make an income then great
but money is never as important as your
[ __ ] mental health right so
man [ __ ] uh
social media [ __ ] up your mental health
like i can't even go on a lot of the
social media i go on you know i post an
instagram i'll post a tick tock and i
don't really look at i definitely the
only thing i really kind of look at is
instagram but um
but
this is what you do
if you take a break
you happen to be taking a break you
don't say
hey guys
i'm taking a break
that's the most annoying [ __ ] [ __ ]
sucking ass oh yeah
social media as egotistical [ __ ] guys
just to let you know i'll be taking a
break from [ __ ] social media and
you're just like you don't call your
friends to tell them they're to tell
them you're staying home if they didn't
invite you out like who gives a [ __ ]
hello hey rick what's up yeah hey dude
just to let you know i'm staying home
tonight cool didn't ask
if you'd like to make a call please hang
up and try again
message c five
yeah actually that's true i never
thought about that but that's so [ __ ]
true dude it's so annoying these chicks
with like 2 500 followers are like guys
it's just getting to my brain mental
health is real i'll be taking a break
for a month and then [ __ ] six days
later they're like whoopsie went to
kirks and caicos here's the
undercarriage of my anus oh my god
oh my god i saw [ __ ] that shot where
they shoot it like this where they're
like this i'm unfamiliar and they're
like glutes be popping
wow they're like wow caked up and you're
just like all right
i saw i followed this guy who this is
the worst one i've ever seen he typed it
out on his computer and took a picture
of it oh wow and posted it yeah was it
[ __ ]
like a 70 year old
that's insane he's younger than me oh my
god i love to think of the whole like
imagine him and then yeah
i think he wrote it out in final giraffe
too no he's a right yeah
so bad one wants to flex that he's got
deals i'm sorry to say it yeah wow dude
i don't think he has deals um but
i think that i agree with what
my brother just said but i also just
from personal experience
i've gone through phases where i've been
like without even realizing it just
checking instagram incessantly that's
right that's good and i
and then i've gone through phases where
i'm
at first i'll force myself to stop
checking incessantly and then i just
will stop yeah and now i'm in a place
where like i don't really i think it's
more about how often you check it right
it's not about how much you post it's
about how much you check right yeah yeah
well yeah that's i mean posting is fine
is is what it is that takes no time sure
but also the checking of it is almost up
in my mouth the checking of it is what
makes you
is the is the what makes you feel bad
about yourself yeah so stop checking
right i know what i'm saying yeah but um
stop checking jason and also the first
day you do it is easier the second day
you do it like dude when i get a [ __ ]
burger from in and out the next thing i
want to do is get a burger from in and
out but if i don't eat a burger from in
and out then i don't want a burger for
right now right yeah yeah yeah that's
true too you're being smart today
well
it's not always what the deals are
no we love that guy though jason uh
yellow and he's funny as [ __ ] you should
follow him on tick tock i know he's
taking a break maybe but i'm not on tick
tock i fall on my instagram it's [ __ ]
great you know your boy's on tick tock
because he goes stupid viral right
what's that my [ __ ] goes
don't be viral my your boy is you yeah
me got it and it goes and my my numbers
go nuts okay it's crazy it's like the
doubt some people look at it they're
like what is it this is doubt john like
i don't even understand getting ahead
[ __ ] the way she faces so i have a
quick question
um i have been engaged for
two years
and
i that was cute work yeah 50 60 hours a
week
beyonce works 50 60 hours old
and
you know people ask us like when's the
oh
when are you gonna get married
and you know we don't get the bags baby
you know yeah
so you're young yeah i my question is do
you think it's okay to be engaged for a
long time
and
you know how to respond when people ask
like when's the [ __ ] wedding you know
because none of the bags and you know i
want to get married he doesn't care as
much about as much as me about like
having a big one he's got a [ __ ] you
don't say you know [ __ ] his balls are
underneath i want to but actually you
know it's just not in the cards because
you've got balls on the other side of
his anus you know that's my question so
thanks guys love the pod
thanks uh [ __ ] all those people that ask
when's the date dude when somebody says
they're engaged i don't even think oh
when's the wedding what the [ __ ] are
these people no well i mean this is a
perfect [ __ ] spin move mentality dude
hey when's the date when i wanna and
twitter yeah well yeah moonwalk but i've
never agreed with that but i agree with
it this time yeah but also that how much
is that [ __ ] girl for real the girl
that they would cast in a movie where
that's how she's supposed to be [ __ ]
looking ugly and then she gets done up
and people are like wow when she's even
hot like that yeah i mean she's already
so funny that's what you're saying she's
not yeah that's what i'm saying but like
she would be like like that's how they
would dress her yeah and that [ __ ]
like rachel cook i was just gonna she's
like she's so hot with his glasses on
like that's how that's what it would be
um so uh yeah dude um
it's okay to be engaged for a long time
[ __ ] be engaged for 10 [ __ ] years
yeah dude only be engaged die in game
die engage i agree die have kids have a
whole family never get i have good kids
get married first grow up get married
and be like mom and dad why you're not
engaged be like cause you [ __ ]
people like you [ __ ] keep on
asking spin away have your kid pass on
the spin move mentality that's what's up
made it about the spin movement
mentality but yeah
die engaged that's a good that's a guy
engaged and you get tattoos that say
that die engaged oh that's cool
so german die
yeah yeah yeah um
but uh yeah die engaged dude like that's
awesome as a matter of fact and and and
if somebody asks you unless if you don't
want to do the spin move then do this
move but if somebody asks you when the
date is
just
do a long pause
and
don't answer them so i guess it's not a
long pause just wait until they say
another thing but stare at them
honestly
stereotype tears come out of your eyes
until they say another thing
or
at the or say oh that's an interesting
question when's the what's the last date
you jacked off oh yeah that's good yeah
yeah and then and then they say what and
they say well since we're asking
personal questions yes
spin and [ __ ] you're out so you add a
spin to that
that's the one coolest thing about spin
moves is you can do it before you say
the thing or after you say the thing oh
is that one of the coolest things about
it okay yeah dude good don't sweat the
question dude [ __ ] those [ __ ] well those
people i mean that's just a natural
question to ask i would i don't ask it
come on don't be you i don't ask you i
don't i don't [ __ ] even think it
should be like yo dude come on with that
question just be like that yeah that's
good come on what the [ __ ] are you gonna
be one of those guys yeah before they
even finish the questions
or or go like this go like this yeah
we're engaged and then before they say
anything go like
what when's the date that's good that's
great that's the best one yeah yeah
right yeah
that's the best one actually yeah
scratch everything that we said before
all right next one dude
dj khaled what's up guys
my name is fellman i'm loving the show
i just thought i'd reach out for some
advice
um so i've noticed lately
that whenever i have sex with my fiance
you know i look at myself in the mirror
if there is one nearby oh
my face was just [ __ ] up you know i
just look like adam sandler and little
nikki just all like oh my god
wow
so this one right now
does this face matter during sex um
should i try to focus and work on maybe
making a more sexy face as i'm doing it
you know
or what it's going to just let my face
muscles do what they got to do
thanks
that guy's [ __ ] hilarious also he has
the creakiest [ __ ] floor in
history
what a great question i think about this
often dude i would also suggest just my
advice actually would be a little bit of
a misdirect stop looking in the f
[ __ ] mirror when you're having sex
with you patrick bateman maybe he's
trying to not splurt early and he's just
like you're so hot and he just looks at
himself and he's like whoa i'm ugly by
making those faces [ __ ] it and then the
splirt level goes down okay okay um
oh i there's two things you can do
go fully
fully into it yeah i don't i don't think
you should change yourself yeah you got
to go to
the net what i like to call the next
level right okay you got to go to
another planet you got to go to mars and
say it too when you're about to splurt
sweetie i'm going to mars and then just
go home
right okay so you could do like that uh
oh sweetie we're going and [ __ ] you
know it would be cool if you if you
blast off in ten
nine stupid you gotta get it good though
you got to get right bro you know you
know get it right eight seven prepare
prepare for blast off six five oh oh i'm
going early to bars
you know or or what you can do is if you
don't like that approach going full into
it if there's too many mirrors around
and you get insecure seeing your [ __ ]
ugly face while you're humping
what you can do is
and this really works bro it really
[ __ ] works dude before you have sex
throw in a stick of gum and just
concentrate on this i mean that is
really patrick bateman
what the [ __ ] i'm saying i'm saying
though dude get a job on wall street too
well because then you're just like
but what what what but what is it what
does it help because you're not you're
subconsciously not necessarily thinking
you're subconsciously chewing the gum
and you can't really scrunch up your
face when you're just kind of chewing
your gum and you're it's it's a very
relaxed vibe right
yeah but like this and then you're like
go tomorrow sweetie chewing gum while
you're having sex is not
for
good people it's the [ __ ] it's not
forget the [ __ ] i don't agree
also that's crazy let the face fly dude
just [ __ ] let it rip let the face fly
for sure but i'm saying if he's insecure
about it put a stick of extra in your
mouth
or have a maybe a maybe just a pouch of
gushers and just be eating them just
don't look in that [ __ ] mirror if
you're getting a bj eating a [ __ ]
stack of gushers
don't eat gushers and then they go here
comes the gusher here comes the gusher
in itself if you're
if you're over 10 years old don't eat
gushers when i was gushers was terrible
10 or 11 i ate so many electric blue
gushers that my [ __ ] was electric blue
senator
senator please get back to health care
it's true though it happened senator and
i was
[Laughter]
i was really superimposed over your face
i was really worried about it and uh
then i remembered i ate so many guys
senator those are my poll numbers the
republican
[ __ ]
going yeah
those are my poll numbers i'll ask you a
question okay yeah yeah okay okay
all right yeah don't look in the mirror
just stop i don't know let the face fly
don't look in the mirror you're good
let the face fly you know let the face
fly
hey guys my name is molly i'm a mom of
two boys one who's almost 12 one who is
four so we've got quite an age gap there
yeah
you guys are brothers so i'm hoping you
can help me out with this i have been a
single mom since october 2021 because my
husband is deployed he gets back in
about four months wow i absolutely am
going insane yeah because they cannot
stop picking on each other and it's
constant whining by my little one and
constant frustration by my older ones so
first and foremost is this normal
oh yeah should i expect this for the
rest of their
i don't know teenage lives until they
get out of the house i don't know what
to expect they're complete opposite kids
um
and if this is the norm
what the [ __ ] am i gonna do yeah what do
i do how do i
do i stop it do i let it happen do i
ignore it do i address it do i
you know tell the big one to buck up and
take care like i have
i just i'm to the point where
yeah it is so gross okay
i i just like my little kid will come
running out and i hear him whining and
you'll say mommy and i just look and
turn and i just say no
and then he whines even more so i don't
know
what the best thing is to do so i would
love your advice on this and i'm sure
you guys have some great stories please
tell me what your mom and your dad did
but mom specifically maybe i don't know
you guys thank you so much love the show
thank you i can't wait to hear what you
tell me oh dude remember the time when
[ __ ] we were at the cozy end and oh
and you this is a place in new jersey
that had taylor
ham and eggs right mm-hmm
and uh is that what you call it tell her
him an egg taylor ham can be with
anything but tell her anything but that
was what the question has yeah which is
what i'm asking obviously you're asking
what something's called right but is it
tyler having an excuse on my podcast i
said taylor eggs and ham i think is what
i said that's wrong that's wrong it's
taylor hemings so that's the thing
that's tailored
it's taylor not tailored i understand
that but if if you're talking about the
past tense that the ham was tailored no
because it's
t-a-y-l-o-r and then
you're not getting like a suit snipped
what did you eat taylor
taylor ham correct right that's it and
how was it good it was tailored okay
the suspense is killing me
what happened what happened at the
cosine okay so we were at the coast
again we're at the cozy end and mom was
sitting between us and we were at the
[ __ ] counter and we were eating at
the counter
and you said something that was shitty
and mom turns to me immediately and
[ __ ] goes pop in my face and i was
like what the [ __ ] and she was like you
she was like oh
sorry i meant for matt oh my god yeah
you don't remember this not at all and i
was like well you can hit him now she
hit you nah i mean you know okay yeah i
mean she you know she goes like
not just a little [ __ ] like this like
watch your mouth you know okay yeah well
[ __ ] anyway i don't remember that at
all and i actually don't even think it
happened no i said look you got to hit
mad now she laughs
i mean she laughed dude and she was like
no i'm not going to hit him now i didn't
i shouldn't even have done it to you and
i was like that's not fair that's a good
moment it was so fun dude so i owe you
so i should slap you so one i have a
story myself of my own uh one summer
you were like 14 and i was 11 it was in
our peak picking on each other years
our mom
offered us
70 all right 75 25
to not fight for the whole summer 75
right it was 25 or something like that
to not fight for the entire summer it
was like it was like end of may or so i
think it was ten dollars okay any
[ __ ] way i just you know inflation
you gotta count okay sure factor it in
uh 1.5 so
the day that we agreed to that we were
like so stoked like that's gonna be so
[ __ ] easy i remember we got into her
suburban yeah and within [ __ ] two
minutes of the car ride yeah we're like
punching each other yeah and she was
like all right
the deal's off you get no money yeah but
it was like within a [ __ ] hour we
were like gonna do it for three months
all right we were so stoked about it so
confident and within within an hour we
lost our money and i will tell you this
much and i i know this with my heart it
was your fault i'm sure it was you were
you were the person that cause i was
like this could be easy i can do it for
sure and then you didn't do it and then
shoot and then i was like but i still
get the money and she was like no no
well that's both of you yeah so you owe
me 10 and i get to slap you on the heels
of that i would say the answer is
absolutely you have to expect it with
boys
12 and four it's gonna get 10 11. it
doesn't matter the the thing that might
save her is that eight is a pretty big
gap mm-hmm and eight years like when
he's 18 and the other one's 10 yeah
there might not be a lot of picking on
it the 18 year old might just be at that
point mature enough to not do it anymore
but right until he's maybe at least 16 i
would say definitely expect it also um
it's going to get like t i always like
my friends who are older and have older
kids like i mean calvin's too but like
they say that the teenage years are the
absolute worst for sure they're the
worst yeah for sure but i would say that
because your kid will be like [ __ ] no
and you're like
yeah
yeah yeah yeah uh
talk to the 12 year old
the four-year-old is four what what the
[ __ ] you're talking about you're gonna
do it yeah you talk to the problem and
be like look you're the man of the house
yeah dude you're the man of the house be
a [ __ ] man don't be a little shitty
little brat picking on a four-year-old
[ __ ] four years old you're gonna pick
on him
the kid you gotta talk to the twelve
yeah but don't say it like that be like
dude
i'm really disappointed yeah right i
want you to be the man of the house but
it turns out
you're just not and then turn your head
and kind of turn your body let your body
follow and then just walk away and then
see what he's also saying your father
would also be very disappointed yep yeah
and god forbid and you know maybe you're
together with the father but he's at
work or maybe you're not together with
the father even worse or maybe the
father even passed away which even what
do you forget he's [ __ ] deployed she
said that yeah i didn't hear that come
on back in four months use those four
months as like a but even better dude
like if this keeps up i'm gonna have to
tell him when he gets back if you if you
stop and you know he's gonna i won't
even tell him yep he's gonna drive his
[ __ ]
fleet back or whoever you know maybe
he's with i don't know if he's with the
navy or the air force or whatever the
[ __ ]
doesn't even matter at all yeah like
when he gets back you know your dad's
gonna come back and you know he's gonna
be really pissed off and he's probably
gonna have some ptsd
and he's gonna [ __ ] flip out so okay
well that's not good maybe he saw his
friend die or something like that and
you're gonna [ __ ] it all up just by
complaining about how you have to wear
it [ __ ] them up you're gonna [ __ ] up
the kid if you say that oh [ __ ]
because we have macaroni and cheese
again and your dad's out there watching
his best friends die right i say that
leave that part out and just say the
part about your father would be very
disappointed in you and if you stop now
maybe i won't tell him when he gets home
but if you keep it up i'm going to tell
him and it's going to be very bad for
you oh you're bet oh you're oh i'm sorry
you gotta go to bed at 8 30 tonight when
your dad is out there
burying his friends six feet deep
trudging through the mud holding a half
a body
okay
well let's find out when we get off when
he gets home let's see what matters yeah
you could try that i guess i mean you've
been so
aggressive about it i kind of relented
but i don't think you should try that
but i guess you can because you won't
stop doing we're out there your father's
out there fighting a war that doesn't
need to be fought right wow
and you're pissed you have soccer
practice that's not what's happening
they're picking on each other did you
listen
yeah
no you didn't they're picking up
oh you have to share the batmobile with
your brother when your father's out
there
yeah
yeah twelve and four twelve and four
dude getting [ __ ] by iran
twelve and four has gotta be hard
[ __ ] dude
yeah solid four's hard
and on our own i mean my i i know yeah
god bless for real my son looked at me
today and he's the other day and he said
i don't like dada yeah like okay well
here we go you should have been more
likeable i'm [ __ ] super likable to
him i'm the most likable i don't well
that's obviously not true he said
otherwise no but he doesn't know what
he's saying i made him paper airplanes
all night last night and he [ __ ] took
them and just basically
crushed them like i mean like it took
long i was looking tutorials making i
made an f-16 dude i mean an f-16 it
looked just like an f-16 speaking about
being brothers i remember i could never
make a paper airplane you always could
do it really well you had a book that
had all the different instructions all
about the different ones you could do oh
you got one stuck on you
that's why i got that for you oh
thanks yeah for us for our childhood no
get the [ __ ] out of here that's not why
you did it i swear to god that's why why
you never even told me that it's for me
i don't want to be like [ __ ]
you just want to tell me on the podcast
only yeah it's a symbol of how like of
brothers oh for real i didn't know that
yeah why didn't you ever say that until
now i did say that but you were probably
doing your own thing i was probably yeah
not listening anyway i'm cute i do cute
stuff but yeah
molly
talk to the [ __ ] 12 year old and
expect it to never stop even after you
talk to him but try talk to a
12-year-old the four-year-old's four the
[ __ ] is he gonna change
he's just gonna be four until he's not
four you know he's gonna be five he's
gonna be five until he's not five maybe
when he's out you're good counting ten
maybe you could talk to him then that's
five years later yeah so
just forget about that i'm saying right
the other kid will be 17 by then
talk to the [ __ ] older one
tell him to be the man of the house
yeah man i mean it's like john lennon
said dude wow
i'm not even going to get into it but
that well that's because you don't know
what he said uh cool is that it that's
all we have no we have one more no
another one oh cool
hey matt and chris uh my name is helga i
was just about to pull up the episode of
lifeline but instead decided to share my
wealth of toxic-ness with you guys cool
um so i was wondering if you guys had
any um advice for me it's about a sexual
partner
um him and i have been just randomly
having sex
for about two years
but
um
he hasn't really wanted me to tell
anyone
and
the fact is because he dated
my he did date my best friend oh [ __ ] um
and
so i don't know i've always thought it
was kind of lame like obviously i don't
want to go tell everybody okay i'm
[ __ ] this guy but like
i always thought it was kind of lame
that
i don't know he would even be like let's
not tell anybody yeah so
i you know whatever we continued and now
it's been two years and now like
sometimes i think it's personal i don't
know if that's just my mental health
where i'm like
oh does he not want people to know
because it's me or of me you know
so
um i just don't know what to do when i'm
asking for your advice if i should
either i don't know i feel like there's
a couple options i could either just
drop him completely
which is kind of not fun because the
reason why i do just hook up with him is
is because he's just like a
easy and fun lay like to be honest and
he hopefully says the same about me but
like i'm just being brutally honest he's
fun and he's easy
uh the second thing is like bring it up
to him like tell him like hey i don't
like that we can't really
tell people like
it makes me feel gross and then see how
he reacts but
i don't want that to turn the tap off
yeah
and then or i could just keep going on
with my life and
just feel the way i feel
i don't know or just tell me that this
isn't even that big of a deal and that
i'm being dramatic
because well that wouldn't matter
that could be real too
well thanks for listening guys i so
appreciate it uh life rips and i'm so
happy that you guys have the show
together can't wait to hear it and i
hope to hear your dad on here soon
she's cool too um she's cool yeah i
think that
definitely don't sit on it like if it's
been two years and he's still like oh he
can't do it
don't talk over me but you know what i
mean no you don't know what i mean no
that's what this whole podcast is but
don't
talk over me
worst dad
i think that you don't sit on it you
don't just not say [ __ ] you
i think what you should do is ask him
why
because maybe that will clarify
something and if his answer he's not
gonna say because it's you
if that's the reason but maybe there's
an answer we're not thinking of maybe
has a good reason good right yeah and if
it's a good reason that would change her
feelings it would remove her insecurity
because it's a good reason right and if
he's [ __ ] fumbles over his words or
has a [ __ ] reason or like is clearly
think of a lie then you'd be like oh
well like i this i don't really like
this anymore like it doesn't it's been
going on two [ __ ] years we can't talk
about that's so stupid what are we
[ __ ] 17
like we gotta [ __ ] be adults about
this like
two years is a long time
you know so i think ask him why he
doesn't want to tell anybody don't say i
want to start telling people don't
get any other way about it just
plainly ask him why he wants to continue
to not tell people
i mean his original reason was he
doesn't want people to know because it
was his friend right
that's what we would assume that's not
necessarily what she thinks got it yeah
but she said recently she's just been
starting to think about that it might be
that
i don't know i don't know kind of she
did i think that was implied yeah um
that lately she started thinking about
that maybe it's her
uh
you know what it sounds like dude what
sounds like she might be [ __ ] kidding
herself and she might be getting some
feelings for the guy oh
and i think that you gotta look into
that you gotta check yourself about that
and that's okay if it happened sure yeah
because the truth is man i'm not one of
those like if you want to date somebody
that your friend dated like who gives a
[ __ ] yeah i do it i don't care about
doing [ __ ] it's so lame when people are
like possessive about people that they
used to be with i get it on one hand and
like i you know if my friend started
dating somebody that i dated i might
immediately be like oh that feels weird
but then i'd be like well actually it's
not it's not this life is a long time
yeah this is [ __ ] fine
um
but you might be
feeling a little bit of
it to me it sounds like you want you
you're starting to maybe have a little
bit of feelings for the guy and that's
kind of all i have to say i feel like
maybe you
want people to know because you're
you want to experience the other side of
not just sex i mean yeah you said you
don't want to cut off the tap which is a
disgusting way to put it but also
you um i disagree by the way
it's gross at all look i know like it's
great when you bust off like a sprinkler
but like you know i think that maybe
you're feeling for him a little bit and
that's okay but he may not be
reciprocated if he doesn't want people
to know right not because it's you but
because he feels shady about his friend
or whatever the [ __ ] it is but i would
just tell him and be like bro who cares
we've been [ __ ] doinking for a bit
now and like it was a while ago i dated
your friend and like who gives you [ __ ]
no no no no
he dated her best friend oh yeah
you didn't listen again which is well
then even even more then it doesn't
matter because it's her the one that
being the [ __ ]
yes the quote-unquote bad person it's
not bad but like well yeah but i would
understand why they wouldn't yeah i
would get into especially the same
aspect but like
um
yeah
yeah i mean you're assuming a lot there
though to be honest yeah maybe that's
not true what maybe she's not getting
feelings for him yeah but that's what it
sounds like right when she says that
that's how i feel
okay but i if she's not i didn't that
didn't cross my mind that could be the
case but
assuming she she's not actually getting
feelings for him she's just sick and
tired of not being able to tell anybody
because otherwise why would you care at
all
i know i get it
it's weird after two years it is weird
why we're not allowed to say anything
anybody has it been two years that's
what she said you don't listen to
anybody but that's interesting she
definitely likes him then because why
the [ __ ] would you give a [ __ ] if you
didn't care truly you would be like yeah
i don't want anybody she's explained she
said she's starting to think maybe it's
because it's her and that's making her
insecure no no i know but i'm saying
if she
that's why you know she's getting
feelings no dude no i'm just saying dude
i'm a detective when it comes to [ __ ]
like this then you're like shitty
detective
no way dude i'm like yes
we got some evidence you're a shitty
detective no i'm not dude yes you are i
guarantee she's got feelings for him
there i said it
i [ __ ] said it dude and she's got
feelings for him and i know it dude and
you know what the guy knows it too and
you know what her friend knows it too
about that no one knows no one knows
that i guarantee more people know it
than nobody shut the [ __ ] [ __ ] up
fine dude i have a follow-up question
and tell me how i'm i guarantee she has
feelings for him and i wasn't gonna come
out and be that broad about it but you
know what you back me into a corner
you back me into a corner and i know
that [ __ ] i'm like this i'm like this
okay i also got to bag this that's not
what detectives do ever okay that's what
inspector gets i got one of those hats
that
go you know i mean with no sides just
like a duck bill and a [ __ ] one in
the back
not even something you know those
[ __ ] hats dude
do i yeah those [ __ ] hats
oh yeah you're just thinking yeah
yeah i just think ask him why he he's so
insistent you don't [ __ ] tell anybody
it's been two years get over it dude
[ __ ] people are gonna know
do you like
the way i make you bust off like a
sprinkler yes or no just come out and
say that
not
at all
then i'm tweeting about our relationship
if the answer is no i gladly bow out and
i'm done
just just ask just [ __ ] ask him why
he doesn't want to tell anybody okay
take it from there okay if it's a shitty
answer
be like that's [ __ ] stupid i think
i'm gonna either we
continue and we can tell people or like
i don't really want to do this anymore
yeah it makes you feel gross dude and
you talked over me again and um
or if it's a good reason and it opens
your eyes to
whatever the [ __ ] i don't know what that
could be but maybe there is a good
reason then your mind would not be on
this sort of insecure trail that it is
currently on yeah so you'll do yourself
a favor get the [ __ ] truth answer
true answer from him it's like [ __ ]
john lennon said if you're not in a way
you may if you're right away i make your
bus off like a sprinkler tell people
yeah that he did say yeah yeah all right
cool well you know what dude that's good
lifeline episode nine in the books man
is it episode nine yep nine episode nine
dude episode franken nine and i will do
my dates here boston massachusetts i'm
coming november 12th cheyenne wyoming
denver colorado november 5th and dude
check it out washington dc stockton
atlanta georgia oakland peoria rockford
raleigh
i'll be there chrisley.com so you don't
know if they heard you the first time
you said nah i'm just saying people tune
in and out and i [ __ ] say it for a
second time somebody goes oh i wanna i
live in cheyenne i live in rockford okay
okay
um so yeah so that's good and uh we got
to [ __ ] we're gonna start coming out
with some merch here yeah and uh that's
what's up and uh join our super cult
right yeah man uh so yeah lifeline
thanks and if you have a um what do you
call it uh submission go to [ __ ] uh
watch lifeline at gmail.com
and uh you can is that what it is
watchlifeline.com oh watchlifeline.com
and then you can click on the thing it's
like ask chris and matt or something
right
what is it
watchlifeline.com should have had it up
already i'm at watch lifeline.com and
then click on that and then go to submit
a [ __ ] video we love getting your
videos man give us advice in the
comments give them advice in the
comments
yeah yeah oh look at that looks like we
have a whole website all right guys
uh subscribe and like it helps us out
thank you
hello hello
[Music]